Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History, the podcast which hurtles from ancient Rome to the 1990s at warp speed, cheerfully calling in at Troy and China along the way. This is also a podcast happy on occasion to lift its skirts and show a little flesh, which is handy as joining Dominic and I today is the historian and author Hallie Rubenhold who has specialised in the 18th and 19th centuries in Britain and particularly in the sexual dynamics of the 18th and 19th centuries.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先体验系列专题以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，这是一档以超光速从古罗马飞驰到20世纪90年代的播客，一路上还会愉快地造访特洛伊和中国。这也是一档偶尔乐意掀起裙摆、展现少许春光的播客，这正好派上用场，因为今天和多米尼克以及我一起做客的，是历史学家兼作家哈莉·鲁本霍德（Hallie Rubenhold），她专注于18和19世纪的英国历史，尤其是18和19世纪的性动力学。
Dominic, I should reveal at this stage that I actually met Hallie first not through her history but through her fiction because Hallie, the first book of yours that I um read was uh a novel um Henrietta Lightfoot it was called fantastic mistress of my fate mistress of my fate yes yes that's right yes and and she was she was an 18th century uh kind of following the the Hogarth the uh the harlot's progress um and very very kind of unreliable narrator that's right just tell us something a little bit about her well it's i so i wrote the book i wanted to use really every 18th and early 19th century dramatic trope there was and um and so i i wanted to create a book which
多米尼克，我在这时得透露一下，其实我最初认识哈莉并不是通过她的历史著作，而是通过她的虚构小说，因为哈莉，我读过的你的第一本著作，呃，是一部小说——它叫《亨丽埃塔·莱特富特》（Henrietta Lightfoot），副标题是“我命运迷人的情妇”（fantastic mistress of my fate），对吧？是的，是的，没错，是的，而且她属于18世纪的那种……有点像威廉·霍加斯（Hogarth）笔下的《妓女历程》（the harlot's progress），而且是一个非常非常不可靠的叙述者，没错。给我们稍微讲讲她的一些情况吧。好的，我写这本书的时候，真的想用到当时所有的18世纪和19世纪初的戏剧桥段，嗯，所以我想创造一本书，它
was like tom jones which was like um barry lyndon which was like um fanny hill which was like Tom Jones, which was like Barry Lyndon, which was like Fanny Hill, which was like Jane Austen, but told completely from a woman's point of view and told in a way which was unashamed and, you know, just very front About what women would have experienced Having fallen from I'm not going to say great height Because she was the illegitimate daughter of an earl But having fallen from Respectable society
就像《汤姆·琼斯》（Tom Jones），就像……《巴里·林登》（Barry Lyndon），就像……《芬尼·希尔》（Fanny Hill），就像……（重复）就像简·奥斯汀（Jane Austen）的小说，但完全从女性的角度来讲述，而且讲述的方式毫不掩饰，你知道的，对于女性在从——我不会说“从极高的地位跌落”，因为她是一个伯爵的私生女——但从体面的社会跌落之后，
And then having to make her way As a courtesan And what that was like And the reason why I wrote this was that i have spent a lot of time reading what were called well what are known as whores memoirs um and it's a whole it's a whole genre and it's just absolutely brilliant written 17 18 19th century confessionals um where written by written by actual wh actual halls sometimes by women who engaged in sex work so um Harriet Wilson uh and if you remember Harriet Wilson and and her relationship
然后不得不以交际花的身份谋生，以及那是怎样一种体验，都有着非常坦率的描写。我写这本书的原因是，我花了很多时间阅读被称为——或者说被称为“妓女回忆录”的作品，这其实是一个完整的流派，简直太精彩了。这些17、18、19世纪的忏悔录，是由真正的妓——真正的妓女所写，有时是由从事性工作的女性所写的。所以，比如哈丽特·威尔逊（Harriet Wilson）——如果你还记得哈丽特·威尔逊以及她与
with the Duke of Wellington and uh publish and be published and be damned that's right and and so she actually did write her memoirs, but she's one of the few, and there are lots of other women along the way who men basically voiced their experiences for them. And this became a type of pornography which men could buy. It was very titillating. Sounds like Fanny Hill, right?
威灵顿公爵的关系，“出版吧，见鬼去吧”（publish and be damned），没错，所以她确实写了自己的回忆录，但她是极少数这样做的人之一。一路上还有很多其他的女性，她们的经历基本上是由男性代为发声的。这成了一种男性可以购买的色情读物，非常具有挑逗性。听起来就像《芬尼·希尔》，对吧？
Yeah, well, exactly. Exactly, Fanny Hill. You know, it's a perfect example. You know, what women would have experienced. And what I just couldn't believe was that, you know, I knew that a woman's experience in this world of sex would have been so completely different than the way the men experienced it. And I was just desperate to find that voice I mean there's Harriet Wilson and
对，完全如此，完全就是《芬尼·希尔》。你知道，这是一个完美的例子，展现了女性所经历的一切。而我简直不敢相信的是，你知道，我知道女性在性这个世界中的经历，与男性的体验会是如此截然不同，我当时太渴望找到那个声音了。我的意思是，有哈丽特·威尔逊，而且
and when women write it like Harriet Wilson does she's writing it predominantly for a male audience to a male readership to titillate um but you know the reality of this is that it's going to be so bloody awful for women in many cases and in some cases to be very empowering for women and um and you know and and and every every degree and every shade in between those two things as well and no one ever talked about that so i thought i wanted to write basically an 18th century novel which used again all of those devices and everything but did it in such a way in that we get that other side where she's talking about well this is what happened to me and this is how i survived and you know and actually hate these men
当女性像哈丽特·威尔逊那样写作时，她主要是为了迎合男性的受众、男性的读者群来进行挑逗，嗯，但现实情况是，在许多情况下，这对女性来说简直糟透了，而在某些情况下，这也赋予了女性很大的力量，嗯，你知道的，在这两种极端之间，还有着各种程度和各种色彩的细微差别。但从来没有人谈论过这一点，所以我想，我基本上想写一部18世纪的小说，再次运用所有这些手法和一切，但要用这样一种方式：我们能听到另一个侧面，她在讲述“嗯，这就是发生在我身上的事，我是怎么活下来的，你知道的，其实我讨厌这些男人，
and and you know and i just lie there on the bed and he can do whatever he wants to me and then i'm done and then you know and it's that sort of stuff it's so it's really unromanticized sex in many ways because hallie this this this brings up one of the kind of long-running themes of this podcast which is that um because i write about ancient history where basically you know we know almost nothing and dominic writes about recent history where there's so much dominic presumably you know you've got all these kind of sex surveys and yeah tons kinds of things so if you're writing a history of sex in post-war britain which lots of people have done have no lack of material whereas
而且你知道，我只是躺在床上，他想对我做什么都可以，然后我就完事了，然后你知道的，就是这种东西”。在很多方面，这真的是一种去浪漫化的性。因为哈莉，这引出了这档播客的一个长期主题，那就是——因为我写的是古代史，基本上你知道，我们几乎一无所知；而多米尼克写的是现代史，有那么多的资料。多米尼克，大概你知道的，你有各种各样的性调查，还有成吨的各种资料。所以如果你要写一部战后英国的性史——很多人都写过——你绝不缺材料，然而
yeah yeah if we're trying to trace if we're trying to trace the course you know the way that sexual attitudes change over the course of the 18th and 19th centuries hallie's a kind of indeterminate because there's kind of material there but yeah but nearly as much as there is in the modern day. So where do you find it? Where do you find it, Hallie? Where do you go to? Oh, God. I mean, it just, it's really, well, lots of diaries and lots of memoirs and letters and things like, you know, really personal stuff, which is just so thrilling when you find. And I know it sounds like, oh, you know, oh, titillating thrilling I mean thrilling as in you get I mean this is to me this is what drew me to studying sex historically is that
对，对，如果我们试图追溯历史轨迹，你知道，性观念在18和19世纪的发展变化，哈莉，这就有点不确定了，因为那里确实有一些材料，但远不如现代那么多。所以你在哪里找到这些材料呢？你在哪里找到它们呢，哈莉？你从哪里获取？天哪。我的意思是，这真的——有很多日记、很多回忆录、书信之类的东西，你知道的，那些非常私人的东西，当你找到它们时，那种感觉简直太让人激动了。我知道这听起来好像是，“哦，你知道的，带有挑逗性的激动”，我的意思是，那种“激动”是指你得到了——我的意思是，对我来说，这就是吸引我从历史角度研究性的原因：
there is nothing else which cuts into the psyche and the deeply deeply personal experiences of people in the past of what it was like to inhabit their heads of what it was like to inhabit their heads of what it was like to inhabit their bodies because i mean there is nothing so personal as sex you know and what happens between two people in a bedroom or more than two people in a bedroom or wherever you know is so you know tells you about the personality it tells you about you know what their beliefs are you know are they religious are they what are they afraid of all of these things just kind of come tumbling out and so it's i just think it's a really really direct way into studying the person and here's a question for you how can you
没有什么比这更能切入过去人们的心灵深处和极其私密的体验了，去了解栖居于他们的头脑中是怎样的感受，栖居于他们的头脑中是怎样的感受，栖居于他们的身体中是怎样的感受。因为我的意思是，没有什么比性更私密了，你知道的，两个人在卧室里——或者不止两个人，无论在哪里——发生的事情，是如此地（能够）告诉你关于他们的个性，告诉你关于他们的信仰是什么——你知道的，他们虔诚吗？他们信仰什么？他们害怕什么？所有这些东西都会倾巢而出。所以我只是觉得，研究一个人，这是一个非常非常直接的切入点。这里有一个问题要问你，怎么能——
i mean people are famously um dishonest about their own sex lives. So how do you know when people are being, in their letters or their diaries, how do you, do you just, do you assume that in their diaries, for example, people are being honest or might they be lying to themselves or to some putative reason? Well, sometimes they are lying and that's part of it. I mean, sex is performance, you know, for a lot of people. And, but, you know, know again it's all about context and what you know reading casanova's memoirs you know is it you know is a completely different experience than reading the letters of lady caroline lennox you know who uh with with her sister you know
我的意思是，众所周知，人们对自己的性生活是不太诚实的。那么，当人们在信件或日记中表达时，你是怎么知道他们是否在说实话的呢？你是怎么判断的？比如，你只是假设人们在日记中是在说实话吗，还是他们可能在对自我撒谎，或者是为了某种推测出来的原因而撒谎？嗯，有时他们的确在撒谎，这也是其中的一部分。我的意思是，对很多人来说，性就是一种表演。但是，你知道，这又回到了语境的问题，阅读卡萨诺瓦（Casanova）的回忆录，你知道的，这跟阅读卡罗琳·伦诺克斯（Caroline Lennox）夫人的信件，体验是完全不同的——她和她的姐姐，你知道的，
who's talking about you know married sex and and and you know, who's talking about, you know, married sex and, and, and, you know, what it's like and joking that they're not virgins anymore and they can talk about these types of things. And, you know, so that, and you have to weigh it up. And again, you know, there are all sorts of other things in between. I mean, William Hickey's memoirs, I just think are absolutely fantastic. And Boswell. I mean, I actually, I mean. Boswell. I know, Tommy, you were going to. A Batman.
在谈论已婚妇女的性生活，你知道的，在开玩笑说她们已经不再是处女了，可以谈论这些类型的事情。所以，这就是你要去权衡的地方。而且，你知道，这中间还有各种各样其他的东西。我的意思是，威廉·希基（William Hickey）的回忆录，我真的觉得绝妙无比。还有博斯韦尔（Boswell）。我的意思是，实际上，我的意思是——博斯韦尔。我知道，汤米，你刚想说……一个随从（Batman）？
A Batman, surely. Okay. Yeah. So one of the things that I've been doing over the lockdown is following the lines of buried rivers across London. Yes. So it's something you can do. You can walk. So you go out and you follow the line of a buried river.
一个随从，当然。好吧。是的，所以我在封城期间一直在做的一件事，就是顺着伦敦地下埋藏的河流的路线去探索。是的。所以这是你可以做的一件事。你可以去散步。所以你出门去顺着一条被埋藏的河流的路线走。
And what I find again and again is that um basically red light districts are along the banks of these kind of lost rivers so i've followed the line of the bloomsbury ditch which goes obviously from bloomsbury across what's now the strand and down to uh down to the thames and this was a favorite haunt of Boswell's. He was always there with his... Well, the Strand. The Strand. Well, because you go across the Strand and there was this kind of great snarl of streets, wasn't there?
而我一次又一次发现的是，红灯区基本上都位于这些消失的河流的河岸边。所以我沿着布卢姆斯伯里沟（Bloomsbury ditch）的路线走，它显然从布卢姆斯伯里穿过现在的河岸街（The Strand），一直延伸到泰晤士河。这是博斯韦尔最喜欢流连的地方。他总是在那里……嗯，河岸街。河岸街。因为你穿过河岸街，那里有一大片错综复杂的街道，不是吗？
I think it's Holywell Street, which was notorious as the pornographer's street where you'd go and buy condoms. And so presumably that's where Boswell went and bought his... What was it? His kind of cheap gut or yes yeah yeah yes yeah yes yeah um and and then it all got swept away in the um i think in the 1890s and and made into this kind of you know the old which is one of the most antiseptic places in
我想那是圣威尔街（Holywell Street），它作为色情书刊一条街而臭名昭著，你可以在那里去买避孕套。所以据推测，博斯韦尔就是去那里买他的……那叫什么来着？他那种便宜的劣质安全套，还是……是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，然后这一切都在19世纪90年代左右被扫荡一空，变成了一种——你知道的，“老奥德维奇”（The Aldwych），那是整个伦敦最没有烟火气的地点之一。
the whole of london you say this but you know i mean the thing is you know you mentioned the strand the strand is such an interesting thing and actually the geography of of prostitution in london is is fascinating to follow because the strand has always been a haunt of streetwalkers i mean really since i mean the 18th century 19th century even into you know the early 20th century as well so and but you know the the type of streetwalker changes. You know, so you have, you have, oh, kind of almost in the 18th century, almost a lower middle class type of streetwalker. And then, you know, and then comes, you know, well, I mean, I was going to say they were varying degrees of. So the Covent Garden ones and the Poshwells.
你这么说，但你知道，我的意思是，情况是这样的，你提到了河岸街，河岸街是如此有趣的一个地方，事实上，伦敦卖淫业的地理分布追踪起来非常迷人。因为河岸街一直都是流莺（streetwalkers）出没的地方，我的意思是，真的从18世纪、19世纪，甚至一直延续到20世纪初也是如此。所以，但是你知道，流莺的类型发生了变化。你知道的，你有，在18世纪几乎有一种近乎下中产阶级的流莺。然后，你知道，接着就出现了——嗯，我是说，她们的档次各不相同。所以考文花园（Covent Garden）的和波士威尔（Poshwells）式的……
Well, at various times. Again, you know, okay, so actually I need to read... Well, in Boswell's time. In Boswell's time. Boswell... Well, okay, let me explain. So what was going on? You know, I mean, it's a kind of movable feast.
好吧，在不同的时期。同样地，好吧，其实我需要阅读——嗯，在博斯韦尔的时代。在博斯韦尔的时代。博斯韦尔……好吧，让我解释一下。当时到底发生了什么？你知道的，这就像是一个流动盛宴。
And the interesting thing about sex work is that you can trace, you know, the development of London and the movement of sex work. And it tells you something about, well, first of all, how integrated sex work was into the fabric of society. And, you know, Dan Cruickshank has written about how London was built on the back of sex work. And, you know, that is, I think, largely true. So much money was invested in it.
关于性工作，有趣的是，你可以追溯伦敦的发展和性工作的迁移轨迹。这向你传达了一些信息：首先，性工作与社会结构融为一体的程度有多深。而且，丹·克鲁克香克（Dan Cruickshank）曾写过，伦敦是建立在性工作的基础之上的。你知道，我认为这在很大程度上是真实的。有如此多的资金投入其中。
But also you can trace the growth of London through where elements of the sex industry relocated to. So, for example, at the time that Boswell was out and about, yes, most of it was centred in Covent Garden. So this is kind of 1760s, 1560s. By the time you're getting mid-later part of the 18th century, really the better class of sex worker and the courtesans have all moved, and the movement was starting really by 1760s, into Piccadilly, St. James especially, you had the nunneries, the high-class brothels on King Street, King's Place. And you had, for example, you go into somewhere like St. James Square, whatever, Barclay Square, and you will have the Duke of so-and-so and the Earl of so-and-so's townhouse, and then across the road will be somebody-and-so's townhouse. And then, you know, across the road will be
但你也可以通过性产业各要素重新安置的地点，来追溯伦敦的发展。例如，在博斯韦尔出没的时代，是的，大部分性产业都集中在考文花园。所以这大约是18世纪60年代、16世纪60年代（注：此处口误应为18世纪60年代）。到了18世纪中后期，真正更高档的性工作者和交际花都已经搬迁了——这种搬迁到1760年代就已经开始了——搬到了皮卡迪利（Piccadilly），尤其是圣詹姆斯（St. James），那里有“修道院”（nunneries），即国王街（King Street）和国王广场（King's Place）的高档妓院。而且，举个例子，如果你去圣詹姆斯广场（St. James's Square）或伯克利广场（Berkeley Square）这样的小广场，你会看到某某公爵和某某伯爵的宅邸，然后马路对面就会有某某人的宅邸。然后，你知道的，马路对面就会有某个人的情妇住在一栋宅邸里。所以，你知道的，这一切完全都是融为一体的。但实际上，我认为更有趣的是它比较平淡的一面。它既不是真正的高档，也不是真正的低档，而是像菲茨罗维亚（Fitzrovia）正在发生的事情。因为你知道，随着菲茨罗维亚变得非常中产阶级，你也同时拥有了——你知道的——为内阁制造者、杂货商和中国瓷器商服务的性工作者，以及——你知道的——这些作为性工作者的中产阶级女性，她们住在……我走在夏洛特街（Charlotte Street）及其周围的街道上，我依然抬头看着这些建筑，心想：“哦，某某小姐就住在那里。”因为它是如此深地融入了伦敦的结构和伦敦的地理中。它是如此正常化，并且如此不可或缺地构成了日常18世纪生活的一部分。哈莉，我能问你一个问题吗？我能插话问你一个问题吗？嗯，你谈到了“正常化”，这是一种人们会自愿选择的职业，还是说这是一种由于环境、贫困、皮条客或其他各种原因而被迫走上的职业？
somebody's mistress living in a townhouse. So it's, you know, it's all completely integrated. But what's actually I think is more interesting is the more prosaic aspect of this. It's neither the really high class nor the really low class. It's the, like what's happening in fitzrovia for example because you know as fitzrovia becomes really middle class you also get like the you know the the sex workers for cabinet makers and grocers and china sellers and you know these these middle
两者皆有。绝对两者皆有。而且来自各个阶层，当然在18世纪是这样的。我的意思是，再次强调，当你开始审视这一点时，你会意识到，首先，社会所宣称的和他们实际所做的完全是两回事，这对我来说绝对令人着迷。因为你知道，你会听到一些空洞的官方言论——如果你阅读大量的、嗯，大量的、嗯，道德说教小册子、教育小册子以及当时写的一些书籍，你会谈到：“哦，一个女人偏离了美德的道路，她就毁了。”但实际上，如果你去检验一下，这根本不是真的，实际上，……并非如此。所以你会遇到这样的情况：
class women who work as sex workers living in... I walk around places like Charlotte Street and all of the streets around there and I still look up at these buildings and I think, oh, that's where Miss So-and-So lived. Because it was so woven into the fabric of London and the geography of London. It was so normalised and it was so much a part of everyday 18th century life. Hallie can I ask you a question can I jump in and ask you a question um so you talk about being normalised is this a profession that people would choose
有些下中产阶级的女孩，嗯——我要引用威廉·希基（William Hickey）的朋友托马斯·沃恩（Thomas Vaughan）的例子，他大约有七个女儿，而他是一名律师。在托马斯·希基（译者注：原文如此，实际指威廉·希基）的回忆录中，有一大段内容是他谈到托马斯·沃恩的女儿们。你知道的，他在哀叹自己有太多的女儿，
voluntarily or was it one in which that which they were to which they were driven by circumstance or by penury or by a pimp or whatever it might be. Both. Absolutely both. And from a variety of classes, certainly in the 18th century. I mean, this again, you know, when you start to examine this, you realise how, first of all, what society says and what they actually do are two totally different things and that to me is utterly fascinating because you know you get the lip service you get you know if you if you read um you know a lot of the um a lot of the uh moralizing tracks the educational tracks and things and books that were written at the time you talk about you know oh a woman falls off the path of virtue and she's ruined and actually if you examine that's not true at all that actually um wasn't the case so you have things like
以至于其中一些人不得不沦为娼妓。现在，他这话的意思是，他没有钱支付嫁妆。这就是问题所在：如果你认为自己是向上流动的，或者如果你渴望跨越到更高的社会阶层，你就必须有钱把你的女儿们推到那个社会阶层去。如果你没有，你就会遇到真正的大麻烦，因为你手头有一堆多余的女性，而这个“多余女性”的问题，直到这个国家的18世纪70年代、1880年代左右才真正得到解决。所以你拿这些女孩怎么办呢？她们无法嫁给与她们同阶层的男性，所以她们基本上只能成为妾。这就是在某些情况下发生的事情。你知道的，然后还有那些最终陷入其中的贫穷女性。再然后，还有那些出生在妓院里的女性。
you have lower middle class girls who um and i'm gonna use a friend of william hickey's thomas vaughn who had something like seven daughters and and he was a solicitor. And there's this whole bit in Thomas Hickey's memoirs, which he's talking about, Thomas Hickey, William Hickey, William Hickey's memoirs, where he's talking about Thomas Vaughan's daughters. You know, he's bemoaning the fact that he has so many daughters
你知道的，当你谈论家族价值观时——家族价值观其实也是犯罪价值观。许多家族通过性交易赚取了大量的钱，并且，你知道的，女孩们在妓院里长大，成为性工作者。所以，根本没有什么单一的切入点，有许许多多的切入点。这就引发了一个我们在推特上收到的问题，汤姆，来自jpa。我想如果我们现在可以问jpa的问题的话——jpa说：“怀孕是怎么处理的？它是一段职业生涯的终结吗？”jpa说：“短期内对市场营销毫无帮助，结果就是，你知道的，这是一次强制休假。”是的。预防它很难吗？那么这方面是怎么处理的呢？是的，那是一种职业风险。
that some of them are going to have to turn out whores. Now, by that, he means he doesn't have money for dowries. And this is one of the problems is if you know, if you are, if you see yourself as upwardly mobile, or if you, if you desire to move up in a social class, you have to have the money to push your daughters into that social class. And if you don't, you've got a real problem because you've got superfluous females on your hands and that superfluous female problem isn't going to be one that's really going to be addressed until about the 1870s 1880s in this country so what do you do with these girls they can't marry a man of their class so they're going to have to basically become like a concubine. And so that's what happens in some cases. You know, and then you have poor women who end up falling into it. And then you have women, girls who were born in brothels.
哦，完全是的。再次回到我写的小说，我在小说中相当多地探讨了这一点。如果你的职业生涯——在一个没有有效避孕措施的时代，如果你的职业生涯建立在大量的性行为之上，经常进行大量的性行为，而且你是一个具生育能力的女性，你就会相当规律地怀孕。那么，你该怎么办呢？这就是那些人们不愿谈论的事情所在，甚至人们会压抑这一点，在他们自己的时代里谈论这些会感到不舒服——这就是堕胎。我所说的堕胎，并不是指我们现在所想的那种黑市堕胎（也就是你怀孕四、五个月的时候）。
You know, you talk about, you know, the, you know, family values or family values are also criminal values. And a lot of families made a lot of money through the sex trade and um you know girls were raised in brothels to become um sex workers so you know there was no entry point specific entry point um there were a lot of entry points so that raises a question that we got on twitter tom um from jpa which i think if we can ask jpa's question now jpa said what happened about pregnancy so was it a career ender um it wasn't jpa says not hardly helpful short term for marketing and resulting you know it's a forced leave yeah was it difficult to prevent so so what happens with that yeah that is an occupational
而是指，一个女性刚刚错过了经期。在你能感受到“胎动”之前——“胎动”大约是在三个月左右，当你开始感觉到体内有孩子在动时——人们当时认为那还不是一个孩子。当时有各种各样的民间偏方你可以服用，正如他们所说的那样，来“清理子宫”。事实上，这些东西太容易得到了，以至于它们被登在大多数报纸的头版，比如“胡珀女性丸”（Hooper's Female Pills）。而且，嗯，我想不久前有人对其中一些胡珀女性丸进行了分析，发现其中含有非常高浓度的金属。而这些金属，你知道的，你所做的是服用低剂量的毒物，这会让你病得很重，然后你的身体就会把一切都排泄出去。
hazard oh it totally is and this again you know coming back to the novel that i wrote um this is you know i address this in the novel quite a lot you know if your career well at a time when there is no effective birth control if your career is based on a lot of sex having a lot of sex frequently and you're a fertile woman you're going to get pregnant pretty regularly so what what do you do now this is where really you know the bits that people don't talk about and even people suppress this uh and felt uncomfortable talking about it in their own era which is abortion and abortion i'm not talking about you know, what we think of as backstreet abortions, where you're like four, five months along.
而且，是的，对于女仆来说——女仆是成为妓女的另一种经典途径：你在那里当女仆，然后男主人让你怀孕，接着你被赶到街上。经典套路。据推测，这也是——她们也会诉诸堕胎吗？是的，绝对会。用同样的方式吃药吗？这是——你知道的，太普遍了。这里还有一个有趣的轶事，关于摄政公园（Regent's Park）开放的时候。
But this is, you know, a woman has kind of missed her period. And before you feel the quickening, and the quickening is, I think, about three months where you start to feel the child inside you, it was believed that it wasn't a child. And there were all sorts of home remedies you could take that would, as they said, clear the womb. In fact, these were so readily available that they were advertised in the front page of most newspapers hoopers female pills um and um i think some of these hoopers female pills were analyzed um not that long ago and they found to have very high levels of metals in them and and that was metals you know it's it's what you're doing is taking a low level poison which then makes you really sick and your body expels everything
而且，你知道的，摄政公园里有一个草本植物园，他们发现，我记得在摄政公园开放草本植物园后的一天之内，所有具有堕胎功能的草本植物全都被采光了。所以所有的欧芹（pennyroyal）都被拔光了。这就是当时这种做法的普遍程度。好的，好的，哈莉，我认为这是一个极好的暂停切入点。当我们回来时，我有一个来自迈克尔·龙森（Michael Ronson）的问题要问你。他问：“是什么促成了从放荡不羁的复辟时期（Restoration）到性神经质的维多利亚时代的转变？”听起来像是《糟糕的历史》（Horrible Histories），假设这种特征描述有任何真实性的话。我之所以问这个，是因为我想从一个略有不同的角度来探讨它，这是受我最近的阅读启发而产生的。
um and and yeah for servant girls who are the other kind of the classic way that you become a prostitute is you work as a servant girl and then the master gets you pregnant then you're thrown out on the street. Classic. Presumably, is this also, are they resorting to abortions? Yeah, absolutely. Pills in the same way? It was, you know, it was so prevalent. This is another, there's an interesting anecdote about when Regent's Park was opened. And, you know, they have a herb garden regents park and they found that it's
所以也许我们可以先把这个问题悬置起来。休息回来后我们再探讨。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一抹好莱坞八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，
like i think within a day of opening regents park with with the herb garden all of the aborter facing herbs were gone so all all the pennyroyal was stripped away um uh that's that's how prevalent it was okay okay hallie that i mean that is an amazing note I think on which to go for a break um when we come back I've got a question for you from Michael Ronson who says what precipitated the shift from the randy restorationers to the sexually neurotic victorians sounds like horrible histories assuming there's any truth in that characterization I ask that because I want to put that in a slightly different way, prompted by my own recent reading.
告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告畅听、独家加更节目以及抢先体验现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在与哈莉探讨18和19世纪的性。哈莉，我们有一种感觉，嗯，我的意思是，基本上，对性以及对男女关系理解的这种认识，在我看来，在这段时期里发生了非常非常根本性的变化。这就有点像——
So perhaps we could just leave that hanging. We'll come back to it after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
正如多米尼克所知的那样——他可能没注意到这一点——我读过这本基督教史。哦，天哪，太荒谬了，这太荒谬了。我想是的，所以我读了很多——我读了很多清教徒的东西，对吧？在17世纪，你有一种明确的感觉：男性认为女性比男性要放荡得多，她们具有掠夺性，你知道的，只要给她们一个机会，她们就会试图跟你上床。而最近我一直在读狄更斯，所以我读了很多狄更斯的小说。在狄更斯的小书中，基本上就是“带心的荡妇”（tarts with hearts）。妓女是堕落的天使。女性在道德上更具优越感。
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking to Hallie about sex in the 18th and 19th centuries. And Hallie, we have this sense that, well, I mean, basically, the understanding of sex and the understanding of the relationship between men and women, it seems to me, changes very, very radically over the course of this period. And it's kind of so i as
她们本质上可以说是无性的。总是男性扮演掠夺者的角色，男性在性方面更为活跃。我的意思是，就人们如何理解性、卖淫以及男女相对本性而言，这是一场巨大的文化变革。那么在这两个世纪的过程中，究竟发生了什么呢？嗯，我的意思是，那就像是一整本书的内容，而且我认为，也有很多我们可以质疑这一点的方式。再次，我认为在某种意义上，我想在真正回答这个问题之前，稍微颠覆一下这个问题，那就是：
dominic well knows he may not have picked up on this but i've read this history of christianity oh my god that is that is ridiculous that is ridiculous i think so i so i read a lot about i read a lot of puritan yeah and in the 17th century you have a definite sense that um that men think that that women are are vastly more licentious than men that that they're predatory you know give them a chance they'll try and sleep with you um and recently i've been reading dickens so i've been reading a lot of dickens novels and in dickens essentially it's tarts with hearts tarts prostitutes are fallen angels. Women are morally superior.
你所记录的、你所谈论的，其实是17至19世纪一小部分识字阶层的性行为、实践、观点和意识形态，对吧？他们并不是大多数。
They're essentially kind of asexual. It's always the men who are the predators, men who are the more sexually active. That's, I mean, a massive cultural change in terms of how people understand both sex and prostitution and the kind of the relative natures of men and women so what is what's happened over the course of i mean really that those two centuries well that's i mean that that's that's like a whole book in itself and i think and also i think there are lots of ways in which we can we can question this again i think in some senses you know i want to try to maybe subvert this question slightly before i really answer it which is um what you're recording what you're talking about is the sexual behavior and uh practices and viewpoint ideologies of illiterate class of people from the 17th to the 19th centuries um yeah they were not the majority
因此，绝大多数人是如何生活的，他们所从事的行为和实践，可能与——或者说完全脱离了——那些识字阶层所撰写的内容。所以我们这里实际上有两种历史。而且，你知道的，我们所了解的一件事实是，事实上，工人阶级的性行为并没有真正发生那么大的变化，你知道的，婚前性行为是存在的。通常当一个女性怀孕时，就会有结婚的压力。很多时候，人们会抛弃彼此，你知道的，结婚后，有时人们甚至不会真正去核实这对夫妇是否真的结过婚，仅仅声称你们结过婚就足够了。
so how the majority of people lived their lives and the type of behaviors and practices they engaged in were probably in well were entirely removed from what the literate classes were writing about so we have actually two histories here and and and you know so one thing that we know about is that in fact the sexual behavior of the working classes didn't really change that much, you know, so there was sex outside of marriage. Often when a woman was pregnant, then the marriage would be that then, you know, there would be a certain pressure to get married. A lot of times, people abandon each other. You know, after a marriage, sometimes people didn't get married nobody actually even checked necessarily to see if a couple had been married just saying you were married was enough
所以，你知道的，有时你会遇到这样一种全面、完整的局面：比如一个女性，她的伴侣抛弃了她，他们可能结过婚也可能没结过婚，她可能为他生了一个孩子，然后她又和另一个男人重新结合，接着他们又分手了，然后他们发现……所以你会有一连串的伴侣。嗯，这与狄更斯所谈论的、以及维多利亚时代女性的行为方式完全不同，你知道的，所以那是理想状态，而我所讨论的则是大多数人的现实。现在，更多地回到你刚才所说的关于更大层面的
um and so you know sometimes you had a a whole um a situation where a woman for example um had her partner her partner left her and they may or may not have been married, she may have had a child with him, then she recouples with another man, and then they split up, and they find, you know, and so you have a whole succession of partners. Well, that's totally different from, for example, from, you know, what, you know, this, you know, what Dickens will be talking about, and how Victorian women will have behaved, you know, so that's the ideal and that what I'm discussing is the reality for the majority. Now addressing more to the point what you were saying about this whole kind of the larger
总体问题、关于性如何改变的总体思想上来。我的意思是，有很多事情发生了。这是18世纪爱（love）的引入，这种对兼容性的看法，自然的观念。所以这就是卢梭。是的，卢梭。并且，你知道的，情侣之间，性应该是伴侣式的，你知道的，存在着色欲，而且是女性充满色欲，事实上，你所需要做的就是和一个女性发生性关系，她失去了处女之身，然后她就会变得贪得无厌，接着男性的责任就是通过娶她来控制那种色欲。但这一点到了维多利亚时代就改变了，这开始——
overlying issues, the overlying ideas behind how sex changed. I mean, there are lots of things that happened. It's the introduction of, you know, love in the 18th century, this idea of compatibility, the idea of nature. So that's Rousseau. Yeah, Rousseau. And, you know, that couples, that sex should be companionate, that, you know, there's lust and it's women who are lusty and in fact um all you have to do is have sex with a woman she loses her virginity and then she becomes insatiable and and then the man's duty is to kind of control that
好吧，其实——是的，我的意思是，这确实改变了一点，因为《大卫·科波菲尔》（David Copperfield）中的小埃米莉（Little Emily），众其所知，她堕落了，但尽管如此，她依然保持着纯洁，尽管事实上——我的意思是，但是现在，我的意思是，那只是一个奇怪的狄更斯设定吗？对，好吧，不，但现在我们正在引入一些非常复杂的——你知道的，狄更斯个人对堕落女性的复杂观念。你知道的，狄更斯在哈默史密斯的尤尼亚之屋（Urania House）有他自己的堕落女性收容所。你知道这件事吗？
lust by marrying her but that's that's changed by the victorian period that starts well actually well that yes i mean that has changed a little bit because little emily in david copfield you know famously falls but she still remains pure despite the fact that yeah i mean but now but now i mean is that just a weird dick yeah well no but now we're... I mean, is that just a weird Dickens thing? Yeah, well, no, but now we're bringing in some very complicated, you know, Dickens' personal complicated notions of the fallen woman. You know, Dickens had his own refuge for fallen women at Urania House in Hammersmith. Do you know about this?
你知道……是的。是的，而且——还有他自己的情妇。还有他自己的情妇。你知道的，所以——“言必称圣人，行则如禽兽”（do as I say and not as I do）。而且，你知道的，关于“家中的天使”（angel in the house）这种观念，我想，对于维多利亚时代的男性来说——我很清楚我在这里提供的是男性的视角——对于中产阶级的维多利亚时代男性而言，女性在某种程度上被视为几乎是无性的。但这只是高层中产阶级和中产阶级的情况，而工人阶级呢？那个维多利亚时代的家伙是谁——他与自己的女佣保持着长期的婚外情，最后还娶了她，拍了大量的照片？哦，是的，亚瑟·芒迪（Arthur Munby），没错，他，是的，他对肌肉发达的女性、女佣以及——汉娜·库利克（Hannah Cullik）非常着迷。是的，是的，没错。但是，但是因为我在想，在你关于开膛手杰克和东区（East End）的所有研究背景下，是否存在这样一种感觉：
Do you know about... Yeah. Yeah, and... And his own mistress. And his own mistress. You know, so, you know, do as I and and his own mistress and and his own mistress you know so you know do as i say and not as i do um and you know and but the kind of the idea of the angel in the house i guess that that that for victorian men and i'm very aware that i'm providing the male gaze here but that that for middle class victorian men women are seen as somehow almost kind of
你知道的，穿着斗篷去东区的绅士，那里的女性很穷这一事实，是让这些男士感到兴奋的一部分原因吗？我的意思是，这大概是无法知晓的。嗯，这是一种——你知道的，我认为你所谈论的内容，与“逛贫民窟”（slumming）这种现象有所交集，当时来自西区（West End）的人或富人会去东区，几乎就像游客一样，试图融入那里的生活并参与其中，去酒吧、发生性关系，做所有这些事情，然后坐上马车回到贝尔格拉维亚（Belgravia）的家中。
asexual that but that's that's very upper middle and middle classes and then the working classes who's the um who's the victorian guy who has an ongoing affair with his scullery maid and ends up marrying her and takes loads of photos oh yes arthur mundy that's right and he yes his obsession with muscular women and uh and servants and uh working Hannah Cullick yes yes yes that's right but but but because I'm wondering in the context of all the work you've done on um Jack the Ripper and the East End is there a sense in which um you know the gentleman in the opera cloak going to the East End, is it the fact that the women there are poor?
而且，我认为这——我的意思是，和所有这些事情一样，这真的、真的非常复杂。我的意思是，英国的性与阶级完全捆绑在一起，你无法真正将两者剥离。
Is that part of what makes it exciting for the men? I mean, I suppose it's impossible to know. Well, it's, you know, I mean, I think you're talking, what you're talking about kind of crosses over into this phenomenon of slumming, which was when people from the west end or wealthy people would go to the east and almost as tourists really and try to engage in the life and participate in the life and go to the pubs and have sex and do all these things and then get back in their carriages and go home to belgravia um and um i think this is you know i I mean, as with all of this stuff, it's really, really complicated. I mean, sex in Britain especially is totally bound up with class and you can't really detach the two.
所以，你知道的，对女性的态度——这显然由来已久——是工人阶级女性处于社会最底层，而且工人阶级女性真的不需要太担心为了婚姻而保持纯洁，她们是可以随意处置的商品，她们没有那么受重视，而且人们认为她们天生就具有性吸引力。所以，你知道的，通常一个年轻男性的第一次经历——我想到了沃尔特（Walter），《我的秘密生活》（My Secret Life），如果你熟悉这些令人难以置信的作品的话。我的意思是，它们是什么？我想大约是11或12卷，大约在1888年左右写成，
So that, you know, the attitude towards women and, you know, this obviously goes all the way back, is that working class women are the bottom of the pile and also working class women really don't have to worry that much i mean it about you know keeping themselves pure for marriage and their disposable commodities they're they're not valued as much and it's believed that they're sexualized so you know often a young man's first experience, like I'm thinking Walter, you know, My Secret Life, if you're familiar with these incredible, I mean, they are, what is it? I think it's 11 or 12 volumes written in around 1888,
一直写到1889年、1890年。在这本书里，几乎就是一种意识流，这个男人在回忆……我的意思是，他显然是个性瘾者，其中很多内容也是他自己的想象所夸大的，但你知道，一卷又一卷都是关于与女性发生性关系的记录，其中许多——大多数——都来自较低的社会阶层。而对待下层阶级女性的整个态度就是：她们就是用来被使用和随手丢弃的。这就是浪荡主义（libertinism），你知道的，这就是当时被写下来的内容。但这确实可以追溯到复辟时期，不是吗？
but all the way through, I think, 1889, 1890. And where it's just this kind of almost stream of consciousness, this man remembering what... I mean, he's obviously a sex addict, and a lot of this is embellished by his imagination as well, but, you know, it's just volume after volume of kind of sex with women and a lot of them most of them are of a lower social order and the whole attitude towards lower class women
是的，没错。这就是花花公子（rake）以及随后的拜伦式英雄（Byronic hero）。哈莉，我能插话问个问题吗？你刚才谈到沃尔特，而且我们还谈到了生活在100年或150年前的人，他们略微有些——把他们混为一谈总是存在风险的。
is they're there to be used and disposed of and that's that's libertinism you know i mean that that's you know what's being written but that does go back to the restoration, doesn't it? Yes, that's right. That's the rake and then the Byronic hero. Yeah. Hallie, can I jump in and ask a question? You're talking about Walter and you've talked about, we talked about people who lived 100 or 150 years earlier and were slightly sort of, there's always a danger of lumping them in together.
我好奇的是，所有人都有着相同的品味，还是说人们的实践随时间而改变？换句话说，人们在1750年代或1850年代的日记中所记录的内容，人们是不是一直在做完全相同的事情？哦，是的，是的，人们——我的意思是，人们总是，你知道的，人们喜欢性，这是人类的一种冲动，这是人类的本能。但难道没有一些东西——难道没有、没有那种可以说是“时尚”的东西吗？是的，会有改变的东西。
And what I'm curious about is whether all of these people had the same tastes or whether practices change over time so in other words what people are recording in their diaries in the 1750s or the 1850s have people always done the same things oh yeah yeah people i mean people people always you know people like sex it's you know it's a human impulse it's a human instinct but there aren there aren't things that, there aren't, there aren't, as it were, fashions. Yeah, things that change. Well, I mean, yeah, I mean, they're all fashions.
嗯，我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，全都是时尚。首先，我想说的是，你知道的，我们之前一直在谈论异性恋。其实还有一个完整的同性恋亚文化。当然，对于女同性恋的看法则完全不同，因为人们认为，对于女性来说，这是一种途径——你变得具有性意识的方式是先和一个女性发生性谐，然后你才学会和男性发生性关系，所以这就像是一个渐进的过程——
I mean, first of all, I want to say that, you know, we've been talking about straight sex as well. And there was a whole subculture of gay sex. And, of course, the way lesbians were viewed was entirely different um because it was believed that you know for women this was something the way in which you you can become sexualized is you have sex with a woman first and then you learn to have sex with men so it was like like a progressive so honey can i just yeah interrupt with a question from chris thales who
所以，哈莉，我能打断一下，问一个克里斯·塞利斯（Chris Thales）的问题吗？他问：“在这段时期内，围绕‘性’最大的道德恐慌是什么？18和19世纪的人们会如何看待我们21世纪对性的态度？”我的猜测是——你会说围绕性最大的道德恐慌是同性恋吗？
says what was the biggest moral panic around sex during this period and what would peoples of the 18th and 19th centuries make of our attitudes towards sex in the 21st century and I'm guessing I mean would you say that the biggest moral panic around sex is homosexuality I would in in Britain I would say that around kind of 1800 definitely I would definitely say that's one but then the other thing is you know when a moral panic around sex i mean it's also bound up in you know in other things like like marriage and there was a great moral panic around criminal conversation um in the late 18th and early 19th century where criminal conversation is adultery and um all of these adultery suits being brought and this was
在英国，我会说是的，大约在1800年左右，我绝对会说是其中之一。但另一件事是，你知道的，当出现关于性的道德恐慌时，它其实也与其它事情交织在一起，比如婚姻。在18世纪末和19世纪初，围绕“通奸诉讼”（criminal conversation）曾发生过巨大的道德恐慌。“通奸诉讼”就是指通奸，当时有大量的通奸诉讼被提起，
happening the same time as the french revolution and it was believed it would undermine um britain's confidence in their in their ruling class because you had all of these stories coming out about lady so-and-so in the hedgerows with somebody and and um you know and all these people were gallivanting around and doing you know what the french aristocrats were doing and and and losing their heads as a consequence. And so that was that was also a moral panic around sex. And, you know, and also the thing is about criminal conversation. I mean, people were queuing up around the block to, A, go into the trials and listen to them at the king's bench and then B, to go and buy the transcripts so they can actually read about lady so-and-so with her skirts above her head and her hedgerows um so that you know but i guess
这与法国大革命发生在同一时期。人们当时认为，这会动摇英国人对统治阶级的信心，因为当时爆出了所有这些关于某某夫人在树篱后面与某某人幽会的故事，而且，你知道的，所有这些人都在四处寻欢作乐，做着法国贵族们在做的事，并因此而“失去了脑袋”（意指面临身败名裂或砍头）。所以这也是一场围绕性的道德恐慌。而且，你知道的，关于通奸诉讼还有一点：人们排着长队去A，进入王座法庭（King's Bench）旁听审判，然后B，去购买庭审记录，这样他们就可以真正读到关于某某夫人把裙子掀过头顶、在树篱后幽会的故事……所以，你知道的，但我猜
that's yeah i i guess i i guess kind of you know in you know sex tapes and things i mean that is something that that perhaps we would but i do i mean i do wonder the the thing about homosexuality that um you know it's been in the news recently with Naomi Wolf's new book and Matthew Sweet's response to it. But it is the case that men in the early years of the early decades of the 19th century were being executed for sodomy and i guess that that you know you took someone from 1800 and said well you know you look at britain in 18 in in 2021 i mean that would seem an unimaginable change and i'm kind of interested in that because i uh did a lot when i was young did quite a lot about byron and there's a kind of enduring thesis that the reason that Byron goes abroad is because he basically is, you know, he wants to sleep with boys. And the risk of doing that in England is that he will face a capital
是的，我想，你知道，在某种程度上，性爱录像带和类似的东西，我的意思是，这也许是我们会做的，但我确实在想，关于同性恋的事情，嗯，你知道，最近在新闻里出现了，娜奥米·沃尔夫的新书以及马修·斯威特的书评回应了它。但事实是，在19世纪初的头几十年里，男人们因为鸡奸而被处决，我想，如果你拿1800年的人来说，好吧，你知道，你看看2021年的英国，我的意思是，那将是一个不可想象的变化，我对此很感兴趣，因为我年轻时做了很多关于拜伦的研究，而且有一个持久的论题，即拜伦出国的原因为他基本上是，你知道的，他想和男孩们睡觉。而在英格兰这样做的风险是，他将面临死刑
charge. And as a peer, that's a kind of, that's an absolute no-go, whereas abroad, and the English are kind of notorious for being incredibly bigoted about this. So I, you know, even by the standards of, well, I mean, particularly by the Turks, I mean, this seems to have. Yeah. So, you know, even by the standards of, well, I mean, particularly by the Turks, I mean, this seems to have been Byron's, you know, the great appeal for Byron is that the Turks had a much more tolerant attitude. And it's kind of interesting how completely the pole has swung,
指控。作为一名贵族，这是一种绝对不可能的事情，而在国外，英国人对这种事情的偏见是出了名的。所以，你知道的，即使按照……的标准，好吧，我的意思是，特别是土耳其人，我的意思是，这似乎已经。是的。所以，你知道的，即使按照……的标准，好吧，我的意思是，特别是土耳其人，我的意思是，这似乎是拜伦的，你知道的，拜伦最大的吸引力在于土耳其人有更宽容的态度。而且有趣的是，极端的风向已经完全转变了，
that for us, the kind of the Islamic world is, it's all about repression and homophobia and so on. And we're much freer. Yeah, it is. But it's also, you know, there's also the great tradition. Again, this, you know, ties into libertinism, you know, the great tradition of going abroad to sow your wild oats. And, you know, that's as much with boys as it is with girls. And, you know, the grand tourists who would go around Italy and, you know, they like going to Venice because apparently the Venetian
对我们来说，伊斯兰世界，这完全是关于压抑和同性恋恐惧症等等。而我们自由得多。是的，确实如此。但这也是，你知道的，这也是伟大的传统。同样，这与浪荡主义有关，你知道的，出国播种野生燕麦的伟大传统。而且，你知道的，这既适用于男孩也适用于女孩。你知道的，那些会周游意大利的豪华旅行者，你知道的，他们喜欢去威尼斯，因为显然威尼斯的
women were much more liberal with their favours and then you end up leaving a whole load of illegitimates that you don't have to worry about because nobody can find you after you've left and come back to England and you know that's great you go on your merry way there's that amazing conversation that Boswell has with Rousseau where boswell you know is is basically wants rousseau to tell him that everything he wants to do is great and and boswell's saying you know wouldn't it be all right if i have kind of 30 30 wives and i you know they all have children and i just kind of dump them somewhere wouldn't that be all right and rousseau to give him credit he's saying no that's terrible i boswell was kind of palpably disappointed that rousseau isn't saying yeah go ahead and do it
女性对她们的恩惠要开放得多，最后你会留下大量的私生子，而你根本不必担心，因为在你离开并回到英格兰后没有人能找到你，你知道这太棒了，你走你的阳关道，博斯韦尔和卢梭之间有一场令人惊叹的对话，博斯韦尔你知道，基本上是想让卢梭告诉他，他想做的一切都很棒，博斯韦尔说，你知道，如果我有大约30个妻子，难道不是很好吗？我知道他们都有孩子，我只是把他们随便扔在某个地方，这样不是很好吗？卢梭为了赞誉他，他说不，这太可怕了，博斯韦尔显然感到非常失望，因为卢梭没有说，好的，尽管去做吧。
well you say you know that's really interesting you know this comes back to the question that was asked what would they think of us today and um i i think you know i think they would be horrified i think most they would be horrified at I think most, they would be horrified at women, you know, at the way, I mean, all women, we would all be whores. That, you know, to an 18th century man, all of the women would just be whores. But then at the same time, they'd be absolutely thrilled about that
嗯，你说，你知道，这真的很有趣，你知道，这回到了刚才提出的问题，他们今天会怎么看我们，嗯，我想，你知道，我想他们会感到震惊，我想大多数，他们会感到震惊于，我认为大多数，他们会感到震惊于女性，你知道，从某种方式来看，我是指所有的女性，我们都会变成妓女。你知道，对于18世纪的人来说，所有的女性都只是妓女。但与此同时，他们绝对会为此感到兴奋，
because it would mean that they wouldn't have any responsibility. And I think they would be pretty horrified at our our sexual freedom let's do some questions ali we've got tons of questions from the um from our listeners um so we can probably get through most of them i reckon before the end of the program so stephen clark let's start with stephen clark stephen clark says to what extent was there ever really a victorian taboo about sex? And if so, among which groups and when did it develop and why?
因为这意味着他们将没有任何责任。我想他们会对我们的性自由感到非常震惊，我们来回答一些问题吧，艾莉，我们有来自听众的大量问题，所以我们大概可以在节目结束前回答完大部分问题，我是这么认为的。那么斯蒂芬·克拉克，让我们从斯蒂芬·克拉克开始。斯蒂芬·克拉克说，维多利亚时代关于性禁忌的真正存在程度到底有多大？如果是这样，在哪些群体中，它是何时以及为什么发展的？
So he's basically he's asking about six questions in one. Yes. But do you want to do you have some thoughts on on some or any of these? A Victorian taboo around sex. You know, I think it's really complex and I don't I'm not sure i can give a very pithy answer to this i think you know what started happening certainly even towards the later georgian period is that attitudes towards sex started changing a bit but having said that then that oversimplifies how the georgians viewed sex so um you know usually people will say it accords with the growth of the middle class the literate middle class and the aspirational middle class and the bigger the middle class became um the more they reached for respectability and um and that was that was part that was the motivating force around that i think um uh and
所以他基本上是在一个问题里问了大约六个问题。是的。但是你想，你对其中的部分或全部问题有什么看法吗？关于性的维多利亚时代禁忌。你知道，我认为这真的很复杂，我不，我不知道我能不能对此给出一个非常精辟的回答，我认为，你知道，甚至在后乔治时代，开始发生的事情是，对性的态度开始发生了一些变化，话虽如此，这又过于简单化了乔治时代的人对性的看法。所以，嗯，你知道，通常人们会说这与中产阶级的壮大相吻合，有文化的中间阶层和有追求的中产阶级，中产阶级壮大得越多，嗯，他们对体面的追求就越多，嗯，这就是推动这一现象的动力，我想，嗯，呃，还有
uh but that isn't to say that there ever was a time when you know again i think we try to say that oh the victorians were so repressed actually they weren't they They weren't progress. Any more than, you know, the Georgians were licentious. I mean, you know, it depends what class you were. It depends what your experiences were. So are these just sort of narratives that we've imposed on these periods? Yeah, they are. And they wouldn't have recognised these versions of themselves? Is that what you're...
呃，但这并不是说曾经有过这样一个时代，你知道，再次我认为我们试图说，哦，维多利亚时代的人是如此被压抑，实际上他们并不是，他们并不是进步的。就像，你知道，乔治时代的人是放荡的。我的意思是，你知道，这取决于你属于什么阶层。这取决于你的经历是什么。所以这些只是我们强加给这些时期的某种叙事吗？是的，确实如此。而他们不会认出这些版本的自己？这就是你的意思吗……
It depends who you were talking to, you know. Ruskin, John Ruskin. Oh, well, that's a different story altogether. Yes, John Ruskin, I think not... Too many Greek statues. Yes, not perhaps the best person to ask about that, but Effie may be another story. Yeah, or Dickens. mean Dickens you know he
这取决于你在和谁谈话，你知道。拉斯金，约翰·拉斯金。哦，好吧，那是完全不同的另一回事了。是的，约翰·拉斯金，我想不会……希腊雕像太多了。是的，也许不是问这个问题的最佳人选，但埃菲可能是另一个故事。是的，或者狄更斯。我是说狄更斯，你知道他
overlaps with Ruskin and his obviously his experience is completely different than his yeah it's Walter Walter I was gonna say Walter you know I mean there you go I'll tell you an amazing thing there's a question from James Hancock how influential mainstream was the Marquis de Sade in his time there's an amazing detail that that um Tennyson who in many ways seems the embodiment of kind of um you know high Victorian attitudes to sex when he met with Henry James they talked about the Marquis de Sade and you can't really imagine I mean well Henry James Henry James there So will. Henry James. There's a lot going on under the surface with Henry James. Yes, I agree. Yes, yes, yes. Never underestimate, never underestimate, you know. Just, I think, you know, of course men talked about sex.
与拉斯金有重叠，显然他的经历完全不同，是的，是沃尔特，沃尔特，我本来想说沃尔特，你知道，你看，我告诉你一件令人惊奇的事，詹姆斯·汉考克有一个问题，萨德侯爵在当时有多大影响力和主流？有一个令人惊奇的细节，那就是坦尼森，他在很多方面似乎都是某种，你知道的，维多利亚时代高级性观念的化身，当他和亨利·詹姆斯会面时，他们谈到了萨德侯爵，你真的无法想象，我是说，好吧，亨利·詹姆斯，亨利·詹姆斯在那里。所以，好吧。亨利·詹姆斯。亨利·詹姆斯表面下发生了很多事情。是的，我同意。是的，是的，是的。永远不要低估，永远不要低估，你知道。只是，我想，你知道，男人们当然会谈论性。
Of course Victorian men talked about sex. Whether they recorded it, you know, particular men recorded it, is another question. But Hallie, isn't, is this this an unfair is this again am i providing the male gaze here my sense is that men were kind of expected to know about sex and women were not yes yes i and i'm talking about middle classes here um you know the the novel writing novel reading class well yes i mean is that yes yeah part. Yes. And in fact, we still we still see that. I mean, all the way into the Edwardian era as well, when women become much freer and, you know, and there are lots of...
维多利亚时代的男人当然会谈论性。至于他们是否记录下来，你知道，特定的人是否记录下来，那是另一个问题。但是，哈莉，难道，这难道不公平吗，这难道又是我在提供男性的凝视吗？我的感觉是，人们期望男人了解性，而女人则不需要。是的，是的，我这里指的是中产阶级，嗯，你知道的，写小说和读小说的阶层。好吧，是的，我是说那是吗，是的，一部分。是的。事实上，我们仍然，我们仍然看到了这一点。我的意思是，一直延续到爱德华时代也是如此，当时女性变得更加自由，而且，你知道，有很多……
Lie back and think of England. Yeah, lie back and think of, you know, and again, this is this is where the Georgians differ. So, you know, there was a really fine line where an unmarried or a girl of marriageable age in the Georgian era, she had to know a certain amount, but she couldn't know that much. She had to let the man who was courting her get close enough to her, but not too close. And, and if something went wrong, it, you know, she was ruined. You know, and so there's always that fine line. I think it's the same, you know, Victorian women weren't supposed to know that much, really, because, you know, really, if you had sex outside of marriage, I mean, it was unequivocal.
躺下想想英格兰。是的，躺下想想，你知道，同样的，这也是乔治时代人与众不同的地方。所以，你知道，有一条非常微妙的界线，在乔治时代，一个未婚女孩或达到适婚年龄的女孩，她必须了解一定程度的知识，但她又不能了解太多。她必须让追求她的男人足够接近她，但又不能太近。而且，如果出了什么问题，你知道，她就被毁了。你知道，所以总有那样一条微妙的界线。我认为这是一样的，你知道，维多利亚时代的女性其实不应该知道那么多，因为，真的，如果你在婚姻之外发生性关系，我的意思是，那是毫不含糊的。
You were ruined. You were a fallen woman. And, you know, unless in very bohemian circles or whatever, having said that, you know, again, there's always, there's a rule and then there are all of these contradictions with everything. And, you know, and I think, you know, it's, again, it always goes back to there's what people said and then what people did and how they adapted to that. So, you know, this idea that if you have sex outside of marriage, you know, you'll ruin your spoiled goods. Lots of men married their mistresses, you know.
你被毁了。你是一个堕落的女人。而且，你知道，除非在非常波希米亚的圈子里或其他什么地方，话虽如此，你知道，同样的，总是有一个规则，然后所有这些都与一切相矛盾。而且，你知道，我认为，你知道，它总是回归到人们所说的和人们所做的以及他们如何适应这一点。所以，你知道，这种想法是，如果你在婚姻之外发生性关系，你知道，你会毁了你损坏的商品。很多男人都娶了他们的情妇，你知道的。
Well, here's a good question. So the late Labour Prime Minister Harold Wilson is on Twitter and he says what caused the shift away from public figures having widely acknowledged mistresses so at what point did mistresses as it were go in back in the closet if that's not the wrong expression but you know what I mean yeah yeah that's that's that's a that's a really good question I mean obviously through the Georgian period it was it was acceptable. I think, you know, even in the Victorian period, it was acceptable for men to be seen out and about with women like Skittles Walters and, you know, some of the big name Cora Pearl and the big name courtesans.
好吧，这是一个好问题。因此，已故工党首相哈罗德·威尔逊在推特上说，是什么导致了公众人物不再普遍拥有广为人知的情妇这种转变？那么情妇在什么时候，可以说是回到了衣橱里，如果这不是一个错误的表达的话，但你知道我的意思，是的，是的，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个非常好的问题。我的意思是，显然在整个乔治时代，这是可以接受的。我想，你知道，即使在维多利亚时代，男人被发现在外面和像斯基特尔斯·沃尔特斯以及一些大人物科拉·珀尔和知名交际花这样的女性在一起也是可以接受的。
But obviously when a man got married, you know, he had to have at least a veneer of respectability which didn't mean that he wasn't he didn't still have a mistress somewhere and a house um i i you know i think it's just it's kind of the tyranny of of of middle class um uh so respectability yeah yeah well hallie hallie does i mean this is a serious question although it may not sound it does the career of boris johnson shed light for you on the mores of the georgians it's a good question because actually the thing the thing that's interesting about him is is that it's the kind of shamelessness. Yeah, it is. He doesn't seem to worry particularly about it. And so people just kind of take it for granted.
但显然当一个男人结婚时，你知道，他必须至少保持体面的外表，这并不意味着他没有在某个地方养情妇和房子，嗯，我，你知道，我这只是中产阶级的暴政，嗯，体面，是的，是的，好吧，哈莉，哈莉，我的意思是这是一个严肃的问题，虽然听起来可能不像，鲍里斯·约翰逊的职业生涯能为你揭示乔治时代的风俗吗？这是一个好问题，因为实际上，关于他有趣的事情是，这是一种无耻。是的，确实如此。他似乎并不特别为此担心。所以人们也就理所当然地接受了。
Whereas if Theresa May. I know, I know. I think about this all the time. I think about it. And, you know, and you can say the same about Donald Trump as well. Yes, Trump as well. Yeah. Yeah.
而如果特雷莎·梅。我知道，我知道。我一直都在想这个。我一直在想。而且，你知道，你也可以对唐纳德·特朗普说同样的话。是的，特朗普也是。是的。是的。
It's I just think it's, you know, it's if anything, it sheds light on just how much of the double standard is still with us, which I find quite worrying, quite sad in many ways. It's a really good, he's a really good sort of litmus test of where we are with our acceptance of sexuality and different arrangements in the 21st century. Because I think at any other time, somebody living with their partner and having children in number 10 would just be just like, it wouldn't have happened. I don't even, you know. Unimaginable. Yeah, unimaginable. It wouldn't have even, it wouldn't have even happened in the Georgian era either. I mean, you would have kept your mistress somewhere else.
我只是觉得，你知道，如果有的话，它揭示了双重标准在多大程度上仍然伴随着我们，我发现在很多方面这相当令人担忧，相当悲伤。对于我们在21世纪对性行为和不同安排的接受程度而言，他是一个非常好的试金石。因为我认为在任何其他时候，有人和他们的伴侣住在一起并在唐宁街10号生孩子，那就会就像，那是不会发生的。我甚至，你知道。不可想象。是的，不可想象。这甚至不会发生，在乔治时代也不会发生。我的意思是，你会把你的情妇养在别的地方。
Hallie, you said something fascinating a few minutes ago. You talked about big name courtesans. Yes. So I wanted to ask about that so that's like sort of emil zola's nana or something yeah you know these sort of so it's are these people genuine celebrities and do they acquire a kind of respectability because they're of their big name and how do you become a big name are you particularly good at the job i mean what is what is it that makes you a big name courtesan i think it's a case of creating a certain sort of allure um it's like your marketing is very good
哈莉，你几分钟前说了一些引人入胜的话。你谈到了知名交际花。是的。所以我想问一下，那就像埃米尔·左拉的《娜娜》或类似的东西，是的，你知道这些诸如此类的人，这些人是真正的名人吗？他们因为他们的名气而获得了一种体面吗？你如何成为一个大人物？你特别擅长这份工作吗？我的意思是，究竟是什么让你成为一个知名交际花的？我认为这是关于创造某种魅力，嗯，这就像你的营销非常好，
in many ways and it's it's it's who who you manage to um hook up with um and uh all of the buzz around that, you know, if you are outrageous, like Kitty Fisher, for example, this whole thing about eating a banknote between two pieces of buttered bread and drinking champagne from somebody drinking champagne from her slipper and all that makes her very desirable because she's fashionable and people want to be with her and they want to be seen with her and it's and and and um quarter sands can be status symbols as well and um you know you give it's the joke something about giving your wife pearls and your mistress diamonds or the wife gets pearls and she turns to the husband and she says well what did you give your mistress um mistress? And it's because it's a way of displaying your wealth as a man. Look, I'm so powerful that I can afford to keep this most desirable woman. And I think actually, you know, I mean, if you're going to be in the sex trade in the 18th and 19th centuries, really that is the only way to live your life is like that because you do
在很多方面，这取决于你成功地与谁建立联系，嗯，以及围绕着这一切的喧嚣，如果你很离谱，比如基蒂·费舍尔，例如，整件事是关于在两片抹了黄油的面包之间吃一张纸币，从某人的拖鞋里喝香槟，从她的拖鞋里喝香槟，所有这些都让她非常令人向往，因为她很时髦，人们想和她在一起，他们想和她一起出现，而且，嗯，交际花也可以是地位的象征，嗯，你知道你给出的笑话类似于送你妻子珍珠而送你情妇钻石，或者妻子得到珍珠，她转向丈夫说，好吧，你给你的情妇送了什么？情妇？因为这是男人展示财富的一种方式。看，我是如此强大，以至于我买得起这个最令人向往的女人。而且我认为实际上，如果你要在18和19世纪从事性交易，那么这真的是你生活的唯一方式，因为你作为女人确实有很多自主权，你可以选择谁是你的养家糊口者，嗯，很多女人，你知道的，把她们的牌打得很好，非常明智，而很多女人则不然，她们脱轨了，结果因此死于极度的贫困。
as a woman have a lot of agency you you can choose who your keepers are and um and a lot of women you know played their cards very well and very wisely and a lot of them didn't and went off the rails and ended up dying in complete penury as a result well hallie rather than thinking about women dying complete penury i would like to end this by thinking about them drinking champagne actually a much more much more positive note on which to end i can't thank you enough for this incredible tour over such a kind of complex fascinating range of material can't thank you enough. Thank you everyone for listening. We'll be back next week. Do keep an eye out on Twitter for our subjects, what we're going to be discussing. Send us your questions, your comments, even your corrections. Thanks very much for listening. Bye
好吧，哈莉，与其去想那些死于赤贫的女性，我更想通过想象她们喝香槟来结束这次访谈，这其实是一个更积极、更正面的结束语。我非常感谢你这次精彩的导览，涵盖了如此复杂且迷人的材料范围，我怎么感谢你都不够。谢谢大家的收听。我们下周再见。请务必关注推特上的主题，以及我们将要讨论的内容。给我们发送你们的问题、评论，甚至是纠正。非常感谢收听。再见。
bye. Bye bye. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取独家单集、提前收听和无广告收听。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。